begin dictation Captain's Log
we've been submerged for weeks and are
only now seeing the first signs of the
Sargasso Sea there are far more baby sea
turtles here than I expected and the
Sargassum seaweed is a singular almost
yellowish shade of green and especially
thick
I sent my cameras out to explore and
Dictation the Sargasso Sea is located
here Zuma it's the only sea in the world
that is not defined by any land
boundaries but instead by ocean currents
and it's known for its endemic and
anomalous seaweed
this is Sargassum there is nearly 10
million tons of it floating on the sea
surface as this seaweed has no root
system you might recognize it as it
often washes up on Caribbean beaches
many scientists call the Sargasso Sea a
nursery in the open ocean because it
provides food and shelter for many of
the Atlantic oceans infants most common
our baby loggerhead sea turtles who
after hatching swim here to mature young
eels shrimp crabs mahi-mahi and Marlins
also maturate here in the Sargasso Sea
blue what's that
that thing floating there it's plastic
got to be a plastic the Sargasso Sea is
also home to the North Atlantic Garbage
Patch trash from around the planet
gathers here thanks to multiple
competing currents it's a human-made
maritime disaster that's why we only use
biodegradable plastic on this submarine
and no straws
[Music]
look captain I think one of the infants
is taking a liking to the ship so he has
Brian so he has
[Music]
you
[Music]